[Music]
here is the house where Mercy's well and
walks in white shoes softly down the
corridors of pain only yesterday those
corridors were formed right this with
nurses all platoons of nurses graduated
practical paid and volunteer aid
bringing their competence and sympathy
to the suffering and the sick but that
was yesterday today with more people
than ever before seeking medical
attention with more patience than beds
in hospitals only three hundred thousand
registered graduate nurses on active
service our nation faces a grave and
immediate crisis the lights on the
hospital call board Frank faster today
than they can be handle each one is a
distress signal sent to thousands of
nurses who aren't there who don't exist
but here are three who will ask three
out of the 43,000 American girls who's
very determined then probably a little
frightened
our entering nursing school this year
let's follow one of them betty birth as
she starts out on the crime that will
take her across the threshold of a new
and exciting life the profession and the
privilege of serving humanity
now for a nervous neophyte like Betty
there is pleasure and relief at the
warmth of her greeting this is more than
simple time much of it is in the
appreciation of graduates and other
students that their ranks must be kept
filled that today at least there cannot
be too many new nurses after the
handshakes and the smile though Betty
has to go through registration but kept
her copy of the schedule
her first reminder of the work she will
complete before she can serve those who
may someday neither there are books and
supplies to crowd her first exciting day
but basic studies as chemistry and
others essential to an understanding of
Medicine and Betty learns that there are
emotions in almost every beaker and no
sooner is one class ended that it's time
for the next this one Anatomy without
which you cannot understand or make
yourself understood in medicine
[Music]
there are the precise instruments of
microbiology an introduction to crime
detection in the underworld of man's
almost invisible enemy
Betty learns that taking a census of
deadly organisms could scarcely be
learned at all and the cookie becomes a
potent tool of healing under the name
nutrition and diet therapy and soon
she'll have a nurse uniform will look so
much like a nurse that you'll almost
feel like one see now she's the pride of
her nursing arts class even though for a
patient merry chase chose slight
appreciation of her attention here again
Betty finds the score is of simple
things she did at home but be practiced
with proper Hospital precision all this
concentration however is destined to
make instinctive for hundreds of details
and the work she is preparing for the
habit of parent exactness may some day
he's a suffering fish
[Music]
after months of preclinical work comes a
great occasion
the camping ceremony when Betty and her
successful classmates will be rewarded
with a distinctive cap of their Hospital
once she has the cap she knows he's past
stiff requirements the emotional
satisfaction is deep for this milestone
is marked by ceremonial flame
commemorating nursing's great mentor
Florence Nightingale the lady with the
lamp veneration of a great tradition
means much to these young students
nurses and perhaps the cap means more
men may not understand this women with
Betty starts critical training by
preparing a medication her exactness and
her careful check of each detail in the
delicate matter of dosage are more
important than mere steps in the severe
routine precision here is an absolutely
necessary factor in the successful
treatment of the patient who will soon
receive this medicine and the correct
performance of Betty's job is watched by
an experienced graduate nurse instructor
a human life may someday depend on her
petition
[Music]
treatment three and those everlasting
port it almost think they'd find a
simpler way to keep instruments sterile
but you learned miss burns you will
learn by doing and you get so that it's
second nature to battle the bacteria
and here is everywhere accuracy
forethought and speed no time to wait
but no excuse for error the doctor who
will use this tray cannot take the time
to hunt for any items you might forget
by knowing that they are all in order
and by getting them to him promptly you
have helped him in his vital work
[Music]
getting the right things to the right
places on time is of prime importance in
any organized activity especially in the
work of caring for the sick unless you
have been accompanied by a scratch with
nurses you should not have left that
tray of medicine to help move this
patient your skill makes this an easy
time
[Music]
now that medicines remember well here is
a third change this one in two steps
first ask the patient survey then
compare the card with this official one
to make doubly sure
you learn which patient likes which kind
of bedside manner
and you find that knowing how to keep on
Pleasant easy turn with the six make
your task simpler and help speed their
cures as well often they'll reward you
with a smile of thanks
which makes this worth worthwhile many
phases of hospital work are so highly
technical that nurses must be ready to
help their doctors an almost endless
variety of complex treatments the
Balkans phrase often seen an orthopedic
ward is a challenge to those charged
with speeding a patient's recovery
of course all work and no play we'll
make betting adult girls
but here's fun life work is strictly
conditioned by that old devil time it's
made you almost as quick and putting on
your party clothes as you are with your
uniform
but because the heavy date must be
impressed you take extra special care
he's just starting out on his career too
and any economies are helpful so those
flowers you got from that generous
patient in Maternity this afternoon will
help out and this evening serious
financial problems but you kept them
fresh in the tray room icebox this is
one occasion miss burns when you can
indulge in the luxury of making someone
wait here for a few blissful moments you
are privileged to play a commanding role
you can if you want even forget
tomorrow's assignment in the clinic
[Music]
but you can't forget for law and you've
learned that there's a clock in every
good nurses subconscious mind to make
the goodbyes short and sweet and hurry
back tomorrow is another day a day
without patience and the versatile
hospital personnel which cares for us
only experienced students are qualified
here and the black stripe or Betty's
camp shows that she has over two years
of work behind her cases are so varied
that you will find use for everything
she's learned her hospital moves out
into her community expanding its service
to every citizen this work gives scope
for almost all the knowledge a nurse can
get
luckily Betty's background is now wide
and since her taken run toward pediatric
nursing caring for this young patient is
a gratifying experience
[Music]
training is like the job itself an
accumulation of heaven-sent skills learn
from each one and curacy in time in
temperature deafness in every movement
of the hand a constant determination
that no bacterial invaders can be
allowed it takes all these skills at
more to qualify for surgery for
technical perfection is idolized
so highly trained and coordinated are
the hands and mind of this member of the
surgical team
she is commonly termed the scrub nurse
that they provide as a matter of course
the right instrument at the right
instance he says if there were a link
between her hands and the surgeon frame
if there were not these lightning
fingers falters their failure might
spell death for the sterile team
[Music]
the strain of an operation is almost
overpowering but the patient is okay and
Betty knows that she did well even
though she's glad the supervisor thinks
so too the human touch is everywhere
when you serve humanity and perhaps this
is most keenly felt in the obstetric
owner Suri
here a spurn a septic discipline keeps
human parents off
but mr. Clark the father can present his
car and Betty all suave in sterile
clothes
we'll see if girl car cares to interview
the gentleman through the window
[Music]
well miss burns it looks as if you hit
the jackpot
you've reached pediatric training at
last and what a thrill to be among these
appreciative youngsters it's the kind of
work you've always wanted
[Music]
[Music]
come to the ends of the beginning
graduations that go through years of
third study and patient practice you're
thinking of the oath first born but that
immortal of your sisterhood Florence
Nightingale I solemnly pledge myself
abroad to practice my profession
faithfully to elevate the standard of my
profession and hold in confidence
all personal matters committed to my
keep with loyalty will I endeavor to aid
the physician that his work and devote
myself to the welfare of those committed
to my care
[Music]
yes is it Betty now you're one of this
year's 34,000 will graduate nurses what
lies ahead for these girls in point
well here's your classmate Mary Ballard
typical of thousands who help doctors
and office nurse her counseling and
placement service folder she'd be well
suited to this work and Mary's boss and
hundreds of patients are glad they did
and Thursday Gillespie she chose a
public health career she's bringing
nursing to people who cannot get to
hospital
each will go where she is needed most no
matter where like lieutenant Katie or on
duty at an Army Hospital here awaiting
orders to Yokohama and you miss burns
you are in a hospital at night you and
your little patient and this is Saturday
no date just you and you're looking for
your training
Betty burns you know that this is not
the major emergency in this nerve-racked
rule this is you like thousands of your
sister nurses and hospital staff
assignments have learned to gauge an
emergency it's well you have you may
have saved a life because you know your
job the gentle craft of Nursing has come
a long way down the corridors of time
since this nurse assisted at her first
operation she has seen a hundred changes
and practice and procedure but
nightingales lamp burns brightly in her
heart
way back when she graduated starched and
proud and inspired by the ideal of
service that flame is still bright and
clear and rekindled itself but each
succeeding class of incoming students
[Music]
yes look well at Betty Birds registered
nurse handmaiden to the noblest art of
man healing with skill and stamina with
courage and compassion she is dedicated
to the service of suffering humanity
Birds is a profession and a privilege
yes say it proudly and you need no
further definition she is a nurse
[Music]